well it's a very sunny day I'm gonna try
to clean this off a little bit
there we go that's a little bit better
see the Sun streaming in from up above
our skylight because it's a high noon
here in Milwaukee Wisconsin so welcome
everybody I am going to be talking today
about the social contract and the idea
of it and whether it helps us out here
in America and we can talk about other
places as well in using it as a key
concept in in political philosophy or
ideas although that's for stuff this is
the first of a new set of discussion
that I decided and kind of spur the
moment and then pledged to start doing
monthly as a result of thinking about
you know the protests both here in
Milwaukee and across the nation and
around the world and about policing and
violence and you know where the
different sides resided and sort of
taking stands on contemporary political
issues I do want to try to use some of
my expertise as somebody who studies and
teaches philosophy not to put everything
into the proverbial ivory tower and
above every everybody else but rather to
you know maintain some rigor in the
discussion and bring in some things that
will be useful hopefully for for other
viewers and some of its its classic
formulations and how those differ from
each other and then we'll bring it to a
focus on the present and that's what I'm
intending to do for upcoming episodes I
guess we could call them that or
discussions however we want to frame it
and I do want to mention too before I
jump in as well that we're going to be
having
this topic as the focus for if you don't
already know about the wisdom for life
radio show that airs every Saturday at 4
p.m. Central Time that's a radio show
that that I and my co-host and Hayes
host here in Milwaukee and we picked in
this case the social contract and
whether it's broken as our topic so at 4
o'clock you can tune in you can hear it
anywhere in the world if that's
something of interest to you we also
like you know post it later on and in in
podcast form and video form as well so
let me jump in to the notion of the
social contract itself if we think about
it in really broad terms and we don't
associate it with one particular
philosopher like say Thomas Hobbes or
some of its earlier proto formulation
say and Plato's credo or as we find
discussed when epic Epicurus turns to
discussions about the nature of justice
what we're talking about here is a
fundamental agreement and it's always
you could say fixative i mean there
could be some cases where people
actually do sit down and hammer out some
sort of arrangement and put it into
writing I mean that's part of what
happens when when people have
constitutions that are written
constitutions or when a you know an
organization might drop its bylaws or
things like that you could say that
that's also a social contract of course
an organization is within it's a group
within the larger society right so it's
not the society itself and so to live
bound by a social contract in a very
loose form is somewhat you know of what
is captured by talking about this is you
know we live in a society right when
people point that up and they want to
say okay don't throw your litter on the
ground because then it sucks for all the
rest of us and you're kind of
you know more than your fair share of
public space or something along those
lines right so it's it's we can
understand social contract really really
broadly as this fuzzy but attractive
concept that there's some some basic
fundamental norms that that govern
things and we ought to follow them why
because we in some sense agree to it we
in some sense assent to it we we freely
or perhaps you know less freely through
coercion when when we don't like what
the social contract is saying we we buy
into it is is one way to think about it
and so you know what does this include
well every every social contract in
order to really have some viability has
to have some sort of moral structure to
it it can't just leave everything
totally open and say well everybody's
got different ideas of right wrong we're
not gonna take any stand on that
whatsoever it doesn't have to say for
example stealing you know certain
appropriations of property are wrong or
murder Israel or and it also probably if
it's gonna be effective has to not just
say what's wrong it also has to say
something about what's good and what's
what's right as well and that's where we
get to things that are a bit more
substantive you know so we can talk
about justice as not just say like a
virtue that a single person has but as a
way of describing arrangements of
relations between people or groups of
people or generations or all sorts of
other things as well including the
relations of human beings to as
individuals to groups and to the
governments or to the organs of
governments as they're often called in
older texts what we would call you know
the executive authority so oh there's
that and that brings us to the third
part that has to be there for a social
contract it doesn't work if there isn't
any sort of enforcement aid out of
and we need to fix things it looks like
there we go we had a little bit of
Network instability here might be
something going on here in Milwaukee
could be just the Internet so you have
to have somebody who's actually in force
in the social contract and you know if
you think about what the fundamental
point of having a social contract is one
big aspect of it is to to minimize and
to regulate conflict and disagreement
within the society so you know if let's
take a kind of silly example something
to thank god I've never actually had to
live it and but I think some of some
people may be familiar with from
experience homeowners associations right
here in the United States if you live in
certain neighborhoods they form these
these associations where you know
they're they often can be quite in a
prescriptive about you know what you can
do down to like what color you can paint
your house or how long your grass has to
be okay well people who move in there
and you know buy into that they're
they're informed that there's a
homeowner's association and you know if
somebody wants to say well I didn't know
about these regulations or I never
really agreed to all of it I didn't read
the fine print or I didn't realize that
the board was gonna do this or that you
can say well buddy you you kind of
agreed to it in becoming part of of this
and you know that's the other side to
the social contract there has to be some
sort of benefits to those who are being
regulated by it and within classic
social contract theory that's what we
see in every case there's always
somebody who is or there's always some
way in which you're better off being
under the social contract and not being
under it and so let's talk about one of
the early thinkers and I'm gonna put
aside like you know what we might call
proto social contract thinkers like
Plato in the credo or Epicurus or
anything like that and just talk about
somebody who is infamous in his time
Thomas Hobbes so if you've ever read
Thomas Hobbes Leviathan which is really
you know the book to read I mean if
you're a Hobbes scholar then
you read other books like you know the
day cafe that's all very nice but the
Leviathan and just the first two books
of it because the third book and fourth
book are all this crazy see ology that
Hobbes is trying to get people to buy
into don't even bother with that stuff
from us you're really really interested
in and you know Hobbes conception of God
and its implications for political
theology in any case Hobbes depicts us
as living in this this state of nature
right actually not us because he's
writing to civilize people who are under
some sort of social contract but it's
actually not a very well put together
contract and he says that you know in a
state of nature we're actually in a
state of conflict and it may not be
conflict all the time but you know he
says you know in the state of peace
where the war can always be a walk and
basically we're at each other's throats
and and in danger of losing everything
not just our property but our lives or
our freedom our you know those who
matter to us all that sort of stuff so
in Hobbes is narrative people get
together and they realized this is not a
good way to live we need to have some
sort of better way of doing things and
you know the way that he depicts it is
again totally fictitious but he pictures
people you know each of them reasoning
out that that there are certain laws of
nature that we ought to follow the first
law of nature is that when people are
willing to give up some of their rights
in order to avoid conflict everybody
else should everybody should get
together and and form this agreement now
Hobbes is a big believer in what he
calls the sovereign and this is an
aspect of the social contract you have
to have as we said some sort of
executive somewhat Rousseau will call
the magistrate some sort of enforcement
mechanism for Hobbes its most efficient
if it's a person like say a king writing
this to support the British monarchy and
then you have all the people who work
for them and Hobbes goes so far as to
say that not only do you have does the
King after have a monopoly on force or
it could be a queen as well
and you know there can't be any private
armies or anything like that you also
need to get rid of people bringing up
doctrines that that would in any way
limit the power of the sovereign so you
know he criticizes Plato and Aristotle
and Cicero and all those lawyer
petitioners very no making exceptions
for themselves he says political power
has to be absolute otherwise you risk
falling into war because as soon as you
have factions that can fight with each
other you've got real problems so the
social contract that Hobbes lays out it
is actually encapsulated in a whole
bunch of what he calls laws of nature
right and if you read through these
they're you know they're pretty
reasonable you know all the way down to
like when somebody is trying to you know
deal with conflict and you know it's
trying to parley with them you don't
shoot them you know you don't you don't
kill them but a lot of them have to do
with with other things that are more
basic and and they can even be
understood in a certain kind of and some
Hobbes scholars and said certain kind of
virtue ethics you know describing what
it is to be just what it is to be
forgiving what it is to be grateful all
of those sorts of things and to get
along with other people John Locke is
the next really big thinker in social
contract theory and you know he's often
counterpoise to Hobbes and he is writing
in response to Hobbes what Locke brings
to the table are a couple new points one
is the notion that the state of nature
is not does this bloody you know
terrible war that that Hobbes was making
it out to be but rather it's just a more
unpredictable sort of state where you
can't rely on keeping things as well
it's not as is as well run so you need
some sort of you know society that's
going to be governed by a social
contract in order to have you know
better better outcomes for yourself and
those you care about and and Locke also
thinks that you're entitled particularly
when the executive is
getting too oppressive too tyrannical
according to much power to itself you're
entitled to overthrow them and he frames
it in terms of the legislative and the
executive but it was used you know as a
justification for the American
Revolution and Locke gets brought up in
other cases as well and then the third
big theorist in in the modern period is
of course a Jean Jacques Rousseau who's
got a whole book called the social
contract but he brings up the social
contract as an idea in and earlier on in
the or the discourse on the origins of
inequality among men right and there's a
different sort of story there that
Rousseau is telling that we don't need
to go into too much detail about suffice
it to say that you know we go from
savagery where we're basically you know
cavemen and and very unsocial and we
develop you know language and
agriculture and stuff like that we moved
to barbarism where there are rules but
they're enforced mostly by local little
agencies and they're you know custom
bound and all that and then we move
finally to a more rational form of
society with civilization and a social
contract and for Rousseau social
contracts are I almost always screwed up
right and and so you got to kind of
balance what he says in the book the
social contract against the discourse on
the origins of inequality and some of
the other things he notes that one of
the problems with with civilization is
that they're wind up being these great
inequalities and sometimes they're
inequality say a virtue
meaning moral goodness or capacities and
all that but they very often end up
being more pernicious inequalities
inequalities of wealth inequalities of
power inequalities of social status and
people use their their position to get
more and more for themselves and screw
everybody else underneath them you might
say well why do people accept that
well risso also points out that people
who are in a hierarchy are often willing
to accept a lower role in the hierarchy
provided there's somebody yeah lower
than them who they can they can exploit
and screw over and all that and so you
know what this ends up leading
- is the social contract often being
broken and being broken not not you know
like so in Homs right what could break
the social contract people disagreeing
about things and saying I have the right
to decide for myself I have the right to
go into a faction I have the right to
undermine you know the the society if
it's if it fits what I want for Locke
it's it's more about the tyrannical you
know over oppressive larger government
for Rousseau its whoever is you know
ruling and not just ruling in terms of
political power but also in terms of
wealth so the the economic stuff they
push too much he's sort of like
Machiavelli in that way Machiavelli
thought that the rich and and the few
are almost all well looks like we're
having another internet instability
problem as well there we go we're
reconnected I don't know what's going on
with the Internet here but it's now
starting to storm things even gonna just
this light to get a little bit more
better lighting you know as we went from
super sunny to super stormy so now
there's a fitting fitting place to move
in to talking about the present isn't it
although I do want to talk about two
other thinkers as well and these are
twentieth century late twentieth century
thinkers John Rawls and Jurgen Habermas
so John Rawls is known for his book a
theory of justice and in it he sets out
something that's you know basically a
social contract theory he has another
imagine imagine ative thought experiment
he talks about is all going behind the
veil of ignorance so where we would we
wouldn't know what sort of person we'd
be in the society that we're planning
out and so we don't know whether we're
gonna be a one race or another with race
is even gonna matter we don't know
whether we you know we're completely
healthy or we're gonna have chronic
illness we don't know whether we're
gonna have a ton of kids or no kids we
don't know any of these sorts of things
you know what gender we're gonna be we
don't
about our you know ethnic background
economic situation we don't even know
what we're gonna be interested in how
would a reasonable person set up society
so that other they could buy into it
well Rawls argues that what we would do
then is we would we would pick a society
that's governed by the two basic
principles one of which is that you know
most things should be made equally
available to people within that society
so there's equality of opportunity you
should make it as widespread as possible
and and you should make access to basic
goods as equal as possible as well there
is a justification for making
differences fundamental big differences
sometimes like a doctor earning more
than say the custodian and that would be
that it works out not only for the
benefit of everybody but that it
especially that it works out for the
benefit of the person who is worst off
in the situation so you know that that's
an attractive idea and we can use that
Rawls thinks we can use it as a sort of
guide to reforming our own society
making it more fair and equitable the
other person who I think we want to
think about who's not talking so much
strictly about social contract but does
he have something to contribute is
Jurgen Habermas the German philosopher
still alive today still still
contributing Wow can you hear that
that's that's the the Thunder rain clock
rain sheets coming down and habermas
talks about working out basic norms in
discourse with each other and he says
that everybody whose interests are
potentially affected ought to be able to
participate in the discussion it doesn't
mean that they necessarily hold it all
up but they have to be taken into
account and I think this is this is a
good way of thinking about okay if
there's a problem with the social
contract how do we fix it because social
contracts so here's one one key idea to
take from this
they should remain static they you know
as we make moral progress as we realize
that we made mistakes in the past and
that things need to be fixed or
redressed or somebody's been left out
we're gonna get to that in a moment we
need to be able to fix the social
contract if we're gonna have a social
contract and the reason I wanted to talk
about social contract in the first place
and both both for this and for the radio
show airing later on today is you know I
I saw this this very compelling video
having to do with the the black lives
matter movement and the protests over
George Floyd have now become you know
daily occurrences in many of our major
cities including here in Milwaukee and
it was it was Kimberly Jonz
and she was talking about what was going
on and it's a very short video I'll put
a link to it once this it this stream
actually ends you can just google that
easily and you know one of the things
that she page I'm talking about a social
contract Trevor Noah by the way got
another Trevor Noah by the way it's
coming from South Africa where they had
to work out these issues as well and
it's it's still a work in progress too
he talks about there being a social
contract that would say for example
don't steal right and if so if you do
steal and you're affecting somebody
else's rights and their outcome and
their livelihood who knows what else you
might be you could actually be
threatening their life you steal their
medication some sort of enforcement
agency comes in usually the cops and
says we're gonna arrest you and then the
justice situation justice system will
say make restitution or here's how we
fix this at all oftentimes there's the
it doesn't work out very nicely it's
it's kind of a messy situation and and
process now Kimberly Jonz said why
should we buy into that we've been shut
out from all of this stuff and by we she
was talking about african-americans but
she could be talking about any
who has been outside of the the
overriding social contract it's a very
important question why should we be able
to tell everybody that they have to buy
into it if they're not benefiting from
it and if we might go further the
current configuration of how power works
and enforcement and rules Falls much
more heavily arbitrarily egregiously
unjustly on their shoulders then it does
other people so she was talking for
example about the Football Hall of Fame
and she's saying why the hell should we
care if it gets burned down it's not
ours
why you know you criticize people for
burning down their neighborhood they
don't own their neighborhood and she's
not just talking about economic
ownership she's talking about something
more more basic more fundamental so I
think in the situation of protests and
policing one of the things that we can
bring to the table is this notion that
the social contract perhaps never was
what it was cracked up to be
and you know we could talk about the the
you know the work that Charles Mills has
done and his work his book this the the
racial contract and I think people might
ask questions about that later not that
that's quite useful but we might also
think about how like in the case of
America and we can say this about many
other places as well the social contract
at first is quite narrow you know it
didn't include women they didn't have
equal protection and equal benefits
under how things were arranged and
certainly didn't include people of
different races in some case because it
didn't even include people who didn't
own property and you know so there's all
these different ways in which the social
contract has had to be modified because
people were like this is [ __ ] I'm
supposed to buy into this and follow
these rules and accept the authority of
these these people that are trying to
use power on me but I don't get what I'm
supposed to get out of this you're
treating me like crap you you let other
people abuse me and exploit me
what the hell right and so you know our
response as a society and I think it's
the right response has been to
progressively widen the social contract
and you know again we don't actually
have some sort of document that we drew
up or anything like that but this basic
notion of a wider social contract has
been going on for quite a while and then
there's oftentimes pushback oh you know
you you're gonna make everybody equal
and you're gonna get rid of these these
ways that we've been doing things for a
long time there's always some some
pushback and there's some negotiation
you know like William James says and
when a new idea arrives on the scene
it doesn't just like we don't go from A
to B we always go from something that's
kind of a compromise between a and B and
we get a new truth out of it and I think
we can say something similar in terms of
society now why would Kimberly Jonz be
talking about a social contract and why
would that be useful in thinking about
the current situation with the protests
and policing and racism and you know
which can be understood in a lot of
different ways we can go into that topic
as well well I think she's she's quite
correct that in many cases the social
contract if it's not broken is certainly
in terrible shape and policing is one of
those cases so if you think about the
way the social contract is supposed to
work you're supposed to have sort of
basic norms that everybody's following
in the police are the ones who are
routinely engaging not just in in
violence but in discriminatory practices
in humiliation think about stop and
frisk effectively you know carrying out
kind of a state of terror against some
of the inhabitants of our society and
doing so on arbitrary characteristics
it's you know if you think about race
which by the way is kind of a shaky
notion anyway if you start digging into
it especially the way that we do it here
here in America but any
anywhere else as well if you think about
correlating that to you know what should
go into police and caring about say
criminality or stuff like that there
isn't a you know the connection that
would warrant treating people
differently what we call profiling right
except in some pretty extreme cases and
those are so granular it's not like a
global thing right and so when when we
have this problem with policing when the
magistrate the executive is gone bad and
not just bad in the sense of having a
few exceptions or a few bad apples but
systematically bad I mean bad apples you
rot the whole bunch and this is part of
the problem we we don't see cops turning
other cops in or when they do and report
them they suffer retaliation and they're
taken out of the picture we have a real
problem with how executive authority in
terms of policing is used here in
America it's a big central issue that
we're going to have to do something
about as time goes on and and I think
this is the moment for us to be focusing
these these matters stow all that said
is this whole contract broke is is there
a set of defects in it can it be
remedied what do you do when you have a
social contract that is no longer as
functional as it want to be or it's
become dysfunctional right it you know
the contract itself has become this
oppressive thing well you know that's
where we get to looking at classical
political philosophy
what would Thomas Hobbes come baabs of
fierce with it
don't complain about it because if you
do we're gonna use force on you you can
see where the Thomas Hobbes approach
leads to we're so would say burn it down
start a new one but don't expect the new
one to be great for too long because
you're going to
problems with that one as well
Rawls would invite us to think about how
we might make it more fair how we might
retune it how we might you know if we
put ourselves if we think about our
contemporary situation and thinking
about how policing works then think
about what it would be like if you had a
criminal record and any place that you
went they were reliable to run that and
then treat you differently because we do
you know we incarcerate so many people
here in the United States right or think
about if you were in particular
neighborhoods in a way that we have them
today and you were African American or
just look poor or we could pick all
these things is that something that you
would actually pick you be like yeah I'm
cool as a society like that because I'm
you know I might be that person I don't
think so
well I mean Rawls rectum that Hawk Massa
is much more interest than how do we
actually carry out these discussions now
who gets a seat at the table and I think
that's an important way of reintroducing
the possibility of getting people to buy
in he we need to make things more
representative in terms of our national
politics in terms of our state politics
or cities our communities and you know
those those other units need to be
listening to each other I would say
instead of saying screw those people
over there who want to make things you
know they say it's better we we call it
going backwards you know all you have to
do is like go down the road from from
Milwaukee where we have our problem
we are you know there's a process of
working on right now so some of the
other much more red counties that
surround it and you can
so that's pretty much all that I had to
say I talked for quite a long time I
don't see any questions or comments at
this point I'm not quite sure why
usually I'm flooded with way too many
but I'll take whatever people have to
bring to the table at this time and see
what people have to say and and and what
they want me to respond to or what
points they want to make I know that we
have a kind of worldwide audience
limited of course by viewing time I'm
sure it's midnight somewhere and people
are in bed there but is this this notion
of the social contract something that we
we want to keep is it something that
remains useful or our political life for
thinking about the kind of society that
we want to have or is it too abstract
maybe maybe there is a something to that
maybe there's other concepts in
political theory and philosophy in
history that we should be relying on
instead that's a good question for all
of you viewers where do you fit in that
idea is it something that you actually
find useful I mean it can it can be sort
of a trap when you're when you're too
strongly committed to the notion of the
social contract you get pissed off at
everybody else for seemingly breaking it
you know when we get down to the
granular level where it's like you know
people in your apartment building and
don't they know that you know we
shouldn't make noise at this time those
inconsiderate people alright so I mean
social contract you know sometimes be a
problem but again that has to do with
those of those enforcement mechanisms
maybe part of what we have to do is not
just get the norms right but we also
have to get all the other stuff right as
well you know oh
you know I can see there are a whole
bunch of questions when I did the
pop-out this is kind of weird I couldn't
see any of that in the chat it looks
like I have to do it again so let me try
this pop-out chant here we go alright so
that was wondering where where everybody
was all right let's start taking things
so where's my eyebrow points out bees
will murder their queen if she goes with
the wrong mate yeah okay so I don't know
that that's about social contract I'm
gonna skip over the bee discussion all
right Patrick Walters what about
Montesquieu yeah I mean Montesquieu is
another important early we're looking at
him more in terms of the separation of
powers and then when people actually get
into the spirit of the laws and they you
know I mean it is a head cracker of a
book right that's not this gift they
they'll often like focus on the issue of
how oh you know virtue can be inculcated
and what you know what different kinds
of societies doing a lot of comparative
work there as well let me put that back
let's see here a Stacie ass I don't know
what's happening here but there seems to
be involvement of the natural world like
dolphins really a skeptic here but
something's happening not not sure what
that's referring to in terms of dolphins
but I mean presumably if there is
anything to this social contract thing
and it wasn't just tied to animals of
the sort that we are then once amell's
would reach a certain level of
communication and organization and
rationality maybe they would develop
social contracts of their own all right
Kevin Hornbuckle says oops forgot marks
no because marks doesn't you know marks
the considers the social contract
basically to be ideology we're looking
at people who actually have something
productive to say about it stone crows
with respect to the title people should
read Robert putnams Bowling Alone so
that's actually a good book to bring up
and that's that's you know that brings
up a problem with the notion of social
contract when you have a society in
which people are no it's not just that
they're individuated right it's possible
to have people who are very individual
or say you know race or residency or
things like that a professional group
then it's going to be hard to really do
justice to anything like a social
contract I think all right William
fariah is is Robert Nozick worth
mentioning as a counterbalance to Rawls
perspective I mean here probably not
I mean Nozick people don't know I'm you
know he's an interesting figure the book
to read it began at Anarchy state utopia
which not only goes into a lot of
interesting things in political theory
but also you know like ethical thought
experiments and stuff like that having
my intro class actually read about his
experience machine thought thing and but
you know so so Nozik is is thinking that
we make contracts right we make
agreements with each other but they're
really bare-bones and does that work
very well for late modern industrial
society and very complex political
systems and social systems and economic
systems
I mean libertarians would say that it
does but I mean I don't think so myself
so all right per person there's no such
thing as a social contract well that
could mean a lot of different things
none of the social contract theorists
say that people actually sat down and
like wrote out a social contract in
every case and if that's all you mean we
can be an agreement if you if you want
to say that the idea has no merit don't
know what you're doing here all right
Negra cornelio I have a problem with my
teacher he's saying Camus is not an
existentialist I'm saying is I'm saying
I'm not understanding can we what can I
do now well as far as your teacher goes
you're screwed because you're the you're
the student and he's the teacher she's
the teacher but as far as truth goes cow
Moo is an existentialist there's
existentialism in the you might call it
the broad big picture sense and then
there's existentialism in much more
narrowly restricted senses Camus calls
the people like chefs tough Jasper's and
Kierkegaard existentialists right and so
when he's rejecting existentialism he's
rejecting that he's also differing with
Sartre but he fits within the
existentialist spectrum same thing goes
for Heidegger same thing go for Mark
Marcel you know your teacher just is
being kind of a jerk all right let's see
your Stacy Washington Russo's boring
can't wait for a live am and Albert
Camus well you might wait a while yeah I
think it's too bad you find we're so
boring I find him fascinating but you
know like there could be a difference in
temperament Jordan says I wonder if ooh
Cody in an approach helpful at all right
now I again ben has some interesting
ideas Hyneman does indeed have some
interesting ideas he sort of stepped in
it lately this is a response about
coronavirus has earned himself much hate
within the the philosophy or you might
say I like to get my Foucault straight
from call it you know I mean food code
so this is a much larger conversation
the idea of a social contract in any
sort of like strict sense for code would
reject right he's when he's talking
about power he says the power is not
just about violence it's not just about
consent it lies somewhere in the middle
and it's free people and net but the the
notion of the social contract
historically Foucault talked about that
quite a bit it can be it can be quite
useful to make sense out of things all
right
steward Lindstrom Juneteenth runs the
risk of becoming just another brand with
performative white allies Juneteenth de
Sales and black lives matter merchandise
what can we do to stop this inevitable
occurrence keep doing the the stuff that
that isn't that you know I mean you can
say the same thing about any movement
right and then answer the same way I
mean we can say the same thing about
modern stoicism people like it's just
become a self-help fan well then quit
reading the crap stuff and read the good
stuff you know I actually practice it I
mean this seems pretty pretty
straightforward all right Patrick Walter
says I think it's important to look to
how the American social contract is Dule
not sure what that's going to mean
Jordan
this co-op social movements progressive
a reactionary depends on whoever will
make the most money that that is quite
true and that is a factor of late
capitalism where that tendency it's not
as if it it wasn't the case say back in
the sixties right think about the
hippies and how quickly the
counterculture became co-opted right it
was in full swing by the 70s but it
happens in a much quicker way today
whereas people are pointing out swag
becomes readily available and and and
you know that doesn't have to detract
from from what's going on though I mean
you can you can that can be true and it
can also be true that there can be
vibrant communities I mean think here in
Milwaukee
we've had protests for now more than two
weeks
they're coalescing into something
they're gaining more organization
there's even like alternative protests
going on with people who don't like the
leadership of the main protests and
there's a lot of all sorts of nexuses of
things going on as well all right we're
gonna Andrea says meanwhile the elites
support the revolt so they can
annihilate the last of the white middle
class yeah I don't think so
that that that seems pretty far-fetched
to me that's assuming that the white
middle class has a certain sort of
homogeneity that it doesn't and probably
buying into some trusting narratives
alright I'm just skip over some of these
comments that are not particularly
relevant Jordan writes profiling over
sentencing for the same crime is rampant
yeah and this is this is a big problem
here in America we have great
disparities in sentencing and it's not
just a problem in particular communities
and their courts with say race right
it's also a problem across communities
so you know we used to have an
expression when I live
in Indiana which was come on vacation
leave on parole because Indiana would
give people very long sentences for the
same crime it might have gotten them
half that time or a third that time in
Kentucky or Michigan or Ohio or Illinois
and that's that's a real big problem you
know another big problem is once it's
once it's discovered that sloppy police
work or active malice on the part of
prosecutors got somebody behind bars and
they're proven to be innocent as like
the project Innocence Project that
doesn't actually get them out there's a
whole bunch of other things that have to
be done and there's never
I mean there sometimes there's civil
cases but there's almost never any real
restitution for that sort of thing
people's lives are ruined by the way
policing works and it's it's really it's
so tragic and it creates a kind of
resentment and righteous indignation at
seeing the sort of things that the
police get away with all right here's a
here's a silly question from Kevin
Hornbuckle and Sadler going to morph
into an sjw so I think people who use
the term SJW do so because they're
sloppy thinkers and I you know it's am I
gonna morph into that so I'm a virtue
ethicist I've been teaching philosophy
studying philosophy you know teaching
for 20 years studying for 30 years if
Aristotle was around today you probably
would think Aristotle is an sjw just
based on what he would say coming out of
nickim Achaean ethics book v on justice
and you can add that to that stuff
that's in you know the politics as well
so I mean if you if you think I'm
morphing into an sjw this channel
probably isn't for you all right kiss
Booker says the police should be there
to serve the people not to repress them
that's exactly it that that is a
fundamental problem it's not just that
the police are are primarily interested
in repressing people although we do have
way too many
who are interested in policing so that
they can be the big man or big woman
with a badge and get to exercise power
on people we need to have weight better
screening and the screening has to be
continually done and the bad apple cops
we need to get them the hell out here
right and they need to be prosecuted
just as if they were any other will get
an unstable connection again there we go
all right we're back I would say that
policing is is less simply about
repressing people or humiliating people
and it's more about perpetuating its own
structures and now that's not to say
that there aren't cops who are in it for
the right reason but there are so many
pressures on them to cut corners and do
things the wrong way in in the
contemporary setting so that is a really
significant problem when you lost the
pop out chat when I lost the thing let's
see what we got here all right do looks
like you don't have all the chance so
let's pick up Jordan SJW a term used by
reactionaries to disparage left-leaning
arguments that's not just reactionaries
it's it's sloppy thinkers of all sorts
and it's you know it's sort of like
calling people snowflakes or things like
that it's it's a substitute for actually
thinking things out and when people do
use language like that whether they're
on the right or the left they lose my
respect and that's that's an issue all
right here's the question from Hetty
mental do I have an opinion on the
potential for a third party candidate
this year like libertarian Canon
candidate Joe Jorgensen Ritz is Andrew
yang I see almost no potential for a
successful third-party bid not just this
year but until we radically change
things and and so this is where I is an
independent you know somebody who can't
actually identify with any of the
available parties but is willing to use
my vote strategically this is this is
one reason why I'm so so against
gerrymandering gerrymandering
drawing these districts in in weird ways
it doesn't just favor which whichever
party is is gerrymandered you know
positively in that way it also like
totally negates any any any
effectiveness of third parties involved
in it so that's a big problem the way
that we set up elections really goes
against third parties we don't let them
into debates which is a problem with our
media so III don't see a third party
really getting much traction at all this
this time around and then they always
get accused of being splitters and stuff
like that all right
Lennie penny how do we know if the
differences in outcome between races is
motivated by systemic racism agents have
it better and lots of dimensions is this
also systemic racism sure it can be I
mean systemic racism or systemic racism
as we call it is when there's different
outcomes because of the way systems are
set up and you know I suppose you can
say the consolation for those who want
to always talk about Asians by the way
is so a great podcast or listen to a
great podcast about why people shouldn't
buy into that by one of the people that
I follow on Twitter how do you know if
the difference we didn't be in outcomes
is motivated by it or it's not motivated
by it but actually a product of it do
the stance oh look
follow through on on the stuff I mean
it's not that hard to do
alright let's skip over the stuff about
social justice I think we've said enough
about that
here's another boneheaded comment by pro
Goni
systemic racism is code word for anti
White's not helpful at all alright new
card I think the first thing people need
to do is take a deep breath and calm
down okay what then
all right let's see here
William asks in the absence of a
sufficient number of shared basic root
values can the social contract be
sustained depends on whose version of
the social contract it is write per
person the social contract theory has
always been false okay that's that's
it's great that you could like announce
that and I guess we didn't have to have
this at all you know or talk about these
ideas it's it's amazing that's something
that I've been like reading and teaching
about for years and years I kind of like
just not wasted my students time with it
it's totally false all right
insult Patrick does goodness philosophy
that we won't be able to adhere to him I
don't know it a good as such philosophy
means but I think there's some
usefulness to the notion of a social
contract and I'm not saying that it's
useful in every condition or situation
or that we can read it into all the way
that some of its proponents might have
liked to do but I think that it can be
something that's useful and people do
refer to it so I think we have to
address it all right Kia says what might
need to change for the court systems
well that's a great question so I think
that we should look very closely at how
prosecution works because before the you
know people who are accused actually
gets into the court system is such that
have their day in court there's very
often a lot of stuff going on between
overworked public defenders and
prosecutors who have all sorts of
resources at their disposal and are
incentivized to get as many convictions
as possible and we'll you know quite
often lie to the people who are they're
engaging with and get them to plea
bargain things down which then now a
person has a criminal record right which
can be used against them the next time I
think we also need to start looking
carefully at and how judges are ruling
and make them more accountable it's very
tough to do because as I've said in so
many other places here in America we
don't really have systems for things
instead what we have are all sorts of
subsystems that kind of fit together in
different places all right all right
Robert
says it's the jails for long as they
build jails they'll be a problem I mean
I think we're always going to need some
some prison and penal system it's a
question about
we're going to do it and and I think the
ways in which we've made our prison
system now is really quite really
inequitable there there's some major
problems with I mean I I've taught in
prisons I see at least in some degree
what what goes on in quite a few of them
so alright I lost the chat again so I
may miss a few people let's see if we
can get this back read James says seems
like the social contract can become a
tragedy of the Commons what incentive to
average people have to uphold their end
am i misunderstanding so these are two
different concepts but they are they can
be connected and you can also bring in
another thing the free rider problem
right so when you have a social contract
and it's functioning fairly well so that
you don't have an awful lot of
violations of it and the violations can
be dealt with well and conflicts between
people can be adjudicated then yeah you
you will have some people who take more
advantage of it than others tragedy the
commons refers to things like you know
overfishing for example and and it's
when you have a good that is being
provided or being you know it's just
they're accessible you could say that
that it's it's been discovered and each
person takes what they want from it if
nobody actually owns it they establish
ownership of it by taking their their
bit and then every you know the
incentive is why I need to get more than
than what that other guys getting so I
and then it you know pretty soon it's
all gone so you know that that can
happen with the social contract in terms
of who gets what but then that's a
shitty social contract and people are
probably not going to stick with it that
long all right and and you're right when
one when people are not benefiting from
the social contract whatever it is and
then they may not always use that term
social contract then they will you know
say
I don't I don't buy into this this isn't
doing any good for me right so all right
sue Vaughn says there's foreign class
elements that have tried to take
leadership of the protest and largely
succeeded that have only served the role
of pacifying the demonstrators uh and
that happened in Denver I guess but it's
not happening here in Milwaukee and it's
not happening in a lot of other places I
don't know where you're getting that
that let's see here new card rights
social justice warriors a specific type
of person who talks about
inconsequential social microaggressions
rather than the serious economic
problems of society I guess if that's
your definition of social justice
warrior there aren't that many out there
because there's there's plenty of other
people who I think you would probably
label as them who are talking about
serious economic problems but you know
and yeah and the man says I think social
contract is a bit privileged I wouldn't
know what to replace it with they think
that people who don't agree with the
current social contract probably don't
have the means to leave yeah I mean I
don't know what you mean by social
contract is privileged privilege is
something that we would apply to people
but I mean I don't think that we have a
single social contract in place I think
we have a whole set of connected things
and I don't think that the social
contract adequately explains the the
entirety of society or so that you know
the political system or the economic
system or something like that but you're
right that a lot of people are stuck in
a situation and this is one of the
problems with social contract theory the
notion that well if you don't like it
you're free to leave
Friedel even where you know a lot of
people can't even like leave their
particular town because they don't have
the resources to do so they can't change
neighborhoods they they have a difficult
time moving from one place to another
even if they get the opportunity to do
so they may be quite unwelcome there and
people will make it quite clear to them
all right let's see here William says
they're some types of worldview
sufficiently incompatible that they're
not subsume Abunda one social contract
if so if the you is the u.s. approaching
this difficulty there's all sorts of
world I mean this is a Hobbs point right
he thought that almost did every place
Oh worldview was it was a problem and so
you get rid of them right
get rid of Aristotle and Cicero yeah
there's gonna be some there's gonna be
plenty of points of view that generally
are gonna be one form of tribalism or
another and they they prioritize their
own group in their own way of looking at
things and say everybody else can kind
of suck it right and if they get a
chance to to impose their own power they
will and and that leads to is Tom
pointed out once once you start doing
that you do have the problem of faction
a problem that by the way goes all the
way back to Plato and Aristotle they had
some really great discussions of that as
well is the USA approaching this
difficulty I would say that in some
areas we are and with some groups we are
and it's it's funny because you know if
you're on the right it's the leftists
who are the big problem with that and on
taifa and all that you know crazy
conspiracy theories about them you know
bringing in busload of them and I got to
say that from from you know effectively
the center motivated by by virtue of
ethics right now the rights looking
pretty friggin bad you know I've had
periods of my life where I've been much
more critical of the left and its
culture than the right but right now I
see bigger problems there so yeah all
right Mike Finney says dogs have a
social contract when they meet and
decide to play and how to play and when
to stop because one goes too far I don't
know that that's a social contract as
such I think you need more in order to
have that you can say that they have
some they they seem to observe basic
norms of behavior but yeah I don't know
alright let's see
George writes an educated society is a
just society at least social engineering
should focus on educating the people
that would be nice
education is pretty low here in America
in our K through 12 and even in our
colleges and universities I am not
particularly impressed with the job that
many of my academic peers are doing many
of them would think they're doing a
great job or you walk into their
classroom and you're like holy crap you
know there's a great book years ago by
arum and I'm forgetting the name of his
co-author called academically adrift
that's really worth reading because they
use the best proxies that they could for
figuring out whether better educated
will to do with like left you know the
leftist professors or anything like that
and more to do with the commodification
which by the way is run by neither left
nor right but business interests
primarily of Education in America so
yeah we've got it we've got some real
problems all right Robert says as long
as they construct prison to resolve the
issues of the lower classes there will
continue to be this problem in society
that'll be as part of it I mean we're
not we're not in a massive prison
building phase I'll give you an example
again here in my home state in the 1990s
we built a lot of prisons here in in
Wisconsin and they haven't built a lot
of new ones since then because they've
got plenty there but once you've got
prisons there's a natural tendency to
want to find ways to keep those prisons
filled and so prison reform is often a
tough tough sell all right a new card
says if anything we need a more tolerant
and skeptical perspective as Montaigne
said it makes no sense I think our
beliefs are so true that we've burned
others at the stake in order to defend
them yeah I mean you can you can
actually have some very strong beliefs
and also think that maybe other people
ought to be allowed to talk and you know
that that we don't have to burn them I
don't think that you have to be
skeptical and do that all right
Alfredo asks what could be mentioned
about freedom of speech was will tear
right I disagree with you but I'll fight
for your right to say what you think it
seems many people get angry when when
people disagree that's quite true and it
there's a lot of I mentioned the word
tribalism there's a lot of tribalism
right now in terms of people lining up
we can also call factionalism as well we
are probably more divided at this point
in time than we have been across the
culture for quite awhile and that's a
problem and a good bit of that is not
just due to like social forces it's good
of individual failings there's a lot of
vicious people out there
in terms of their ability to entertain
to thoughts that might be different at
the same time and not get caught up in
narratives of those are the devil and
I'm the good guy or you know these are
my protectors and they're the good guys
or something like that so that you know
and people do get angry when
disagreements arise over moral issues
Plato noted that in the gorgeous and the
credo and the Euthyphro and not in the
credits are in the Euthyphro and in a
few in in other places as well like the
Republic so this is not a new dynamic
it's been exacerbated I'd say by social
media and the 24-hour you know news
cycle and stuff like that and the you
know essentially a commodification of
outrage that that's going on as well but
going back to your other thing what
could be said about freedom of speech I
mean the social contract to come back to
that basic issue right should allow for
some some freedom of speech it should
allow for people to exchange ideas if it
doesn't then I mean in Hobbes's you know
was willing to accountants at least some
freedom of speech just you can't like
undermine the government's or you know
teach teach moral or religious theories
that that would have implications that
the government's doing the wrong thing
but I think you know most social
contract theories would have to say we
want a pretty wide freedom of speech
right you think about Rawls is this
point of view would you want a society
where you can't express yourself or or
not all right all right let's see here
Eric says is what happens in u.s.
related to what happens in the world
with the rise of authoritarianism how do
you see relations between what happens
in the US with what happens in Arab
revolutions and the role of social media
so - two interesting questions there
yeah authoritarianism is is on the rise
and you know there's a lot of people
when they did like psychological
profiles of Trump voters and you got to
be kind of careful with this stuff you
know these generalizations but it was
really interesting that they found that
the the thing that you did unites them
together was authoritarian attitudes and
you look at the fact that he's managed
despite being a you know base right of
people who will say that he's right no
matter what and you know that that is
probably driven by authoritarianism and
there's you know psychological needs and
you could talk about well what's what's
prompting that well you know probably
the erosion of fairly settled ways of
life the fact of massive inequality
growing between rich and everybody else
whether it's middle class or poor or
even you know like upper middle class
right the distance between them and the
people who actually call the shots is
immense you know the Internet has in
fact been kind of an unsettling thing as
well it's allowed all sorts of cool
stuff to happen but it's also allowed
all sorts of new networks to develop and
you know you look at you if you look at
the world so let me let me back up a
little bit if you think about like the
optimism in the 90s right and Fukuyama's
often you know made fun of end of
history thesis that we're gonna get more
and more you know liberal democratic and
stuff like that and there's really not
going to be any viable opposition to
that okay that was kind of kind of
nonsense when it was proposed but a lot
of people didn't didn't you know
catch that and there's a tendency for
people to think other things are gonna
get better and better and better well
you know there's nothing that says that
that liberal democracy has to
automatically succeed liberal democracy
in the sense of like a basic consensus
about rule of law you know leaving
leaving power when you're actually
kicked out instead of like leaving
poisons and pills behind a certain
fairness and how you engage your
opponents and stuff like that all those
sorts of things
you know Universal franchise all those
sorts of things right there's nothing
that says that that has to be the case
think about the 1920s and 30s right
liberal democracies oftentimes without
great you know long-established reach
you're just falling and falling and
falling and falling you know by the time
that Poland was invaded Poland wasn't
the democracy Poland was a military
dictatorship and it was being invaded by
two other you know fascist and a
communist power not to say that that was
that made it okay or anything like that
but you know all these these things
liberal democracy if you read like the
political theory books of the 1920s the
40s which I used to do back when I was a
grad student and I was interested in
like seeing what people thought at that
time a liberal democracy was only one
option among among a number of them and
and you know if you think about the
world that we're in today many of the
great powers how democratic are they I
mean India is still a democracy and the
BJP is on the retreat I don't know that
the Congress party has really that much
to offer I mean they the reason why the
BJP was able to supplant them was the
years and years of corruption the
Congress party and you know look at
China
think about Brazil you know we're I was
thinking the other day about how we
talked about brick right Brazil Russia
India China these big countries well
they're they're all essentially now run
by authoritarian governance right these
these massive important developing
countries that we talked about in the
90s
now the Arab Spring thing is kind of
interesting are the protests that are
going on is there something like the
Arab Spring in terms of what the social
media was able to do I'd say yes there
is probably nothing that has been more
galvanizing for people who are on the
left and in the center and even some of
the people on the right then seeing
video after video after video just
straight footage of cops abusing their
authority attacking people engaging in
barbaric behavior that's unjustifiable
and knowing that if it wasn't for that
video they'd be totally getting away
with it
animation they're still getting away
with it most of those cases that made a
huge impression that I think we're
seeing a sea change right now at least
with respect to race and and issues like
that all right
Linden asks I wonder are the implicit
informal psychological contracts and
expectations an issue by the same way
that a formal law can be toothless
without buy-in on a day to day well yeah
I mean it's one of those things where it
works until it doesn't and then what do
you do right you think that and this is
where a lot of people who don't you know
they're not used to having the cops
involved and they're used to just like
going over to deal with their neighbors
sort of like face-to-face and everything
going along hunky-dory when they get
into tougher situations or like I don't
know what to do and then they
immediately call the cops right so all
right Ken Blackwell did the police and
us operate theoretically or otherwise
under the concept of policing by consent
it's interesting that the police in many
other countries are called police and
not law enforcement I mean we use the
word law enforcement of law enforcement
officer Elio pretty synonymously and I'm
not sure what you me
by policing by consent we have these
things called consent decrees but
they're often not particularly effective
but I'll say this in a general way when
the police don't actually get buy-in
from the community they lose their
legitimacy and they can do so by
behaving in bad ways and then
reinforcing that by taking their own
side and not punishing their own not
policing their own as we often say right
so that that's that's an issue Stacey
says speak about the social contract and
traditional philosophical views
including Locke's views on slavery and
write a lot of black friends your chat
to learn and become interested in
philosophy well thanks for inviting
friends
I mean Locke's views on slavery we're
not particularly enlightened I should
say right and this is a big problem for
most of the thinkers there's actually a
really great thing out there in
thousand-word philosophy it's a short
piece about how we want to approach
philosophers who have taken what we
consider be you know wrongheaded and
morally repugnant positions I mean Locke
was not somebody that we want to look to
not just in terms of slavery but also in
terms of the Native Americans here in
the Americas and other indigenous
peoples who he considered to be
unreasonable and I mean I don't know
that there's that much more to say about
that we don't want to there's there's
like no intrinsic connection between
that I would say and the social contract
is such although you know this is where
we can talk about about Mills and the
racial contract right Mills says that
the notion of the social contract is
essentially something that was just for
white and he's willing to call them
tribes which i think is actually a good
rhetorical move and that you know once
once race was was used it was people
were considered to not be human or if
they're human
they're sort of like you know Aristotle
and sold tools right and and I think
that he's right about them I think that
that's part of why we have much of the
the roots of the systemic racism that we
still do have in our society and the
question is whether we can suitably
expand whether you want to call it the
social contract or you know the
community in which we have some sort of
reciprocity and justice and equity and
accountability to each other whatever
construct you want to use to make sense
of this we have to figure out how we're
going to incorporate people who have
been systematically excluded
marginalized left out abused exploited
all these sorts of things and again I
would say that from a basic perspective
of justice and you can call it social
justice if you want by the way first
first people use social justice people
like John Stuart Mill you know and the
Catholic Church right and it's to talk
about things that got left out that
needed to be addressed in a society
developed but I think if you look at
classic treatments of justice they would
say that the african-american community
has been done wrong also all right call
me Shibboleth how does one become bound
by the social contract without consent
is a consent implied yes that's
typically how it's done
and that is probably part of it where
people would be like hey I never agreed
to this crap how are you imposing this
upon me and that goes all the way back
to plato's credo right and the the
argument that the laws are making with
with Socrates some people view that as I
want to get that book up here involving
a conception of the social contract and
I think it gave that book away there's a
guy wrote a book just on that particular
topic
Locke talks about a tacit and voluntary
consent to not just a social contract
but to inequalities
of different sorts yeah this is this is
a problem and I think every so often you
could say that like Hobbes thinks that
once you give your consent it's gone you
can't ever get it back I think it
probably needs to be reworked over and
over and over again we have to have
discussions about this sort of thing all
right let's see here I'm gonna try to
find some new people well this is a good
point by Lyndon Bailey going back to the
video stuff the tone tenor and demeanor
of the bad cops you see on videos makes
them appear like an invading army rather
than a police force I wonder also
effects on things after 9/11
militarization fear etc yeah I mean that
again that is very telling you know they
said picture is worth a thousand words
how much is a video worth where you can
actually see somebody behaving in in
these barbaric ways to the people that
they're supposed to be taken care of and
protecting people who are supposed to be
in their same community a lot of times
they're not in the same community of
course right all right lazeric Maji
what's the difference between American
social contract and European ones is the
social contract I was written or can it
be not what's the main structure so the
social contract is not the same thing
necessarily as a constitution all right
but you could see it as kind of
overlapping but it might include other
things and you know some sometimes you
know for using the social contract in a
very general way to talk about moral
norms that everybody is expected to to
observe although often they don't or
they're you know broken and then they
have to be you know restored in some way
Americans are going to be different than
France you're going to be different than
than Brits right but different French
people are gonna be quite different as
well I mean you think about the judicial
right
the yellow vest movement in part they're
kind of saying hey our social contract
is ruptured and you Parisians and elites
have made things great for yourself and
said screw everybody else and Leo and
Toulouse and the rest of the parts of
the country right and America is is a
very diverse nation in terms of our
social communities as well the states
the local communities and all of that
all right Jacob s in terms of the
American social contract are all parties
equal to all stand in the same relation
of the contract this seems the root
problem that's a good good way to put it
so in the classic way of understanding
the social contract everybody is
supposed to be equal except for the one
who's not equal so like in Hobbes the
sovereign has more power right or the
magistrate and Rousseau but everybody
else is supposed to be on the same level
they could have different things in
terms of wealth right there's oftentimes
a lot of room for that and you know
we've got to protect that that property
in that case and that can subvert the
social contract because other things can
be can be lost other values can be lost
in the process
Aristotle points this problem out
without talking about social contract by
the way in the politics I think it's in
it's not in book five it's in no it
isn't book write the book on status
right well it's also in book two as well
where he talks about the you know the
rich who are the few and the many who
are the free and how each of them
manages to get justice part right and
forget this part long and whom the
counterbalanced and discover look book
five in book seven the virtuous the
people who actually aren't simply yeah
it's both political interest or
something like that actually give [ __ ]
about their society and want to behave
like these
tens you know these these sorts of
divisions all right let's see here let's
get down a bit
Oh just jumped a bit a lot of comments
here and we're getting close to the end
mark hulling says thanks for the QA
you're quite welcome and we'll be doing
more of these monthly all right trying
to scroll up to get to where we were all
right Stuart
it says capitalism has never not been
rate assist in America from the
plantation of white flight and redlining
after the world wars to the
disproportionate amount of
african-americans in Vietnam yeah okay
there's there's there's definitely
something there I wouldn't say that
every single practice or instance of
capitalism is automatically been racist
but I suppose you could say insofar as
it comprises something like a system I
don't
III think it's better understood as a
whole bunch of you know connecting
systems yeah you're you're right
I mean redlining has made Milwaukee what
it is where we have this this you know
we are one of the most segregated large
cities in the United States and and it
has its its effects on education and on
policing and on the criminal justice
system and hospitals and all sorts of
other things job opportunities and
redlining was was it was an important
part of that right so yeah we can talk
about a lot of these things um let's see
here Brenda says dr. Sadler is
politically naive if he thinks politics
isn't war by other means well good for
you Brenda I'm sure that that must be
great when you engage with other people
politically I think there's probably
more to politics than war or by other
means
you might want to read Aristotle's
politics to see if there's anything in
there by the way you'll get to a
discussion about the people who turned
everything into war in book eight with
the Spartans who Aristotle thought were
kind of fuck-ups so all right
Bradford do you think destruction of
property is an effective tool for
bringing social progress probably not
but that's not all that's going on so
you know I don't see how that's I think
that's kind of a red herring there all
right let's see scroll down a bit to see
if I can find some other people we
haven't put like 20 comments already
yeah here's a good point by C CK a zero
seven good point in one sense and bad
point in another sense the Democrats
have created this mess since then
they've been running the large urban
areas for the last 50 years they use the
judicial system as a way to tax the poor
with court fees and fines so if you had
changed it to some Democrats have
created the mess then your statement
would be true the Democrats is not
because some of the Democrats are those
very poor who are getting screwed oh
that stuff right and oftentimes they try
to vote in people who will get the some
Democrats out right now there's a lot of
animus against our Democratic mayor and
maybe he'll face a challenge from from
the left but I wouldn't I wouldn't say
nah Democrats because that's that's not
quite correct let's see here that's
funny Life of Brian aspirin I know she's
moderating I'm moderating I'm probably
not doing a very good job of it here
[Music]
Life of Brian says it's the academic
left wing that's fringe it has assumed
power and obliterated dissent but it's a
self referential bubble of fact justice
well that's some nice rhetoric there
I'm always it's always so funny to see
these people who like have this like
totalizing view of the Academy and the
left they ought to spend some time in
actual colleges I mean if you think that
professors are indoctrinating their
students spend a while with professors
in a classroom and see how hard it is to
get just students to pay attention and
that you can point to
there's a hundred Marquette universities
where all the discussion about social
justice doesn't mean anything where it's
business as usual and where they're you
know they don't even want to let the
grad students have a union or anything
like that so there's this notion that
somehow though you know Academy has been
taken over by the left I got a call
[ __ ] on that as somebody who spent a
lot of time in the Academy and if they
did that I'd be you'd probably see me
fighting the left so the fact that I'm
not is probably a sign
Patrick asks where can we find the radio
program so a Riverwest radio it's called
the wisdom for life show and it airs
4:00 p.m. central on Saturdays my
co-host Ian Hayes and I are going to be
talking about the notion of the social
contract and whether it's broken or not
and you know you can you just go to
River West radio you're right River West
radio calm into your your search engine
and it'll come up and you can click on
the listen live if you want to all right
Brenda has a good good one here this is
coming from MLK do I agree those who
make peaceful revolution possible will
make violent revolution inevitable it's
good again it's good rhetoric I don't
think that it becomes inevitable you can
so break a people's spirit that they
can't revolt at all but that's such a
losing strategy for the people who want
to have power you know and want to
actually be given you know what Hagel
called recognition I mean Hegel's
master-slave dialectic gets way way way
overblown that's not all there is to
Hegel it's not sagal central notion or
anything like that but he is right about
and the interpreters that are right
about one thing one thing the Masters
want is recognition autocannon they want
to be viewed not just as having power
but that power being legitimate and you
know coming come so coming back to the
MLK quote right those who make peaceful
revolution impossible those who stand in
the way of needed changes yeah they're
gonna screw things up and sooner or
later they're gonna lose their positions
because other people are gonna be like
well this is [ __ ] and we need to
revolt here's an interesting question
from Diogenes do I think the large
cities like New York are gonna revert
back to the crime rates they had in the
70s and that is a serious question I
mean we did have some some I mean there
was a reason why people could run on a
law-and-order and you know
rehabilitation isn't working kind of
platform and let's build more prisons
platform after the 70s because crime
rates were pretty high and New York was
out of control do I think we're gonna
see that no I don't i think that we're
you know we're in a different kind of
position now i think we may see you know
quite a bit of violence though in terms
of effectively you know homegrown
terrorism so all right let's see here
so here's an interesting thing called me
Shibboleth what notion of human nature
does underline I had a concept of the
social contract in the first place
multiple ones
I mean Hobbes's vision of human nature
is very stark and it's quite different
than that of lock or Russo or or so many
other thinkers like you know John Stuart
Mill later on so that that's actually a
good question and you could say well the
understanding of human nature you have
is going to kind of drive the way that
you see the the social contract right
let's see
trying to find something that's not back
and forth but I can actually get in here
and say something about
something good destiny here oh here's
here's a question that
lotsa dakka dakka Sadler espoused in a
particular position on tearing down
statues degree of veneration of statues
potential for present ISM I have indeed
and I did so in a podcast that I did
with Tom Ritchie the Tom Ritchie podcast
I think it was about a year or two ago
and we're talking about Confederate
statues in particular and it was
interesting because tom is a you know a
fairly conservative ap history teacher
from the south and you know he's got a
different view on the statues than I do
my view is get rid of all of them
because I'm actually you know I'm a
northerner and I'm from Wisconsin
my family got here in the Civil War
because my ancestor my
great-great-grandfather across the
border to be a higher soldier in the
Vermont you know troops that were being
sent so you know we got here by killing
rebels and Wisconsin actually threatened
to secede from the union if Lincoln
wasn't elected and contributed more than
their fair share of troops to fight the
levels and so I think you know I think
reconstruction should have been carried
out in a ruthless way and you know the
rights of African Americans should have
been enshrined and respected instead of
allowed to be trampled on by white
Southerners who wanted to reinstate a
racist regime so I think I think we
should get rid of all the Confederate
statues I think that the Confederate
flag should be burned in every case
every instance of it should be gotten
rid of just as we would do with Nazi
stuff so I mean people are gonna find me
pretty extreme on that some of my
favorite Civil War statues in fact show
Union troops trampling over the bodies
of Confederate rebels who they they've
killed so we should get rid of all the
statues like the one on Wisconsin Avenue
let's put pictures of those you know now
do we learn any history from statues the
few people do I mean this whole thing is
kind of a red herring and kind of a kind
of a silly thing to talk about and you
know do we get much out of like
destroying statues temporarily we do and
and and in the long run well you know
there's there's something in saying well
we finally are starting to address these
things now let's move forward on more
important things as well so yeah that's
probably a good thing to go out on if
you want to find the thing it's it's the
Thom Ritchie podcast just to type it
into Google and maybe add a search term
sadler and you can hear that podcaster
he and I are going back and forth about
that
radio show on the social contract as I
mentioned Riverwest radio it's called
the shows called wisdom from life so
thanks for all the questions and
comments I didn't get to all of them and
never never do but we're already a
little bit over time and I've got to get
to putting together some clamps content
for a class that starts on on Monday so
I'll see all of you and yeah we'll take
a look at some of the comments that I
didn't get to as I go through the chat